you are coming into my office with this resume without any projects on it.
Do you really think you're going to get the job?
I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I, because you're not getting this job.
Get out.
Run me, play the hell.
Ah, not this guy again.
Wait, check out my projects.
Whoa!
These are actually impressive.
You-you've literally built everything that we had in the job description.
How did he do this?
What he doesn't know is that I went to learn.nextweek.org
and then I just put in the job description
into this box right here
and I asked it to generate me projects
so I can get the job.
Hello.
After that, I answered a few questions,
generated the project and went through it step by step.
The projects are way better than something
clawed or tragedy would give you.
Oh, and then I filled in these questions here
and added in screenshots.
And I could post my documentation to LinkedIn or GitHub.
We even share it to losers like him.
I don't know what's happening here,
but you've got the job, man.
I know I did.
Go open the door so I can go choose my desk.